general motors is doubling down on
electric vehicles and gm is investing
nearly seven billion dollars in michigan
to build a new battery plant and
overhaul an existing factory to make
electric trucks the company says it will
create 4 000 new jobs and
is its largest ever one-time investment
in electric vehicles it's a big deal
people overall jam plans to spend 35
billion dollars by 2025 just around the
corner to make electric cars in an
interview you will only see on cbs
morning's ben tracy sat down with
g-e-g-m ceo mary barra to talk about the
automaker's ev future
and some recent setbacks
we want to lead in evs full stop and so
that's where we're aggressively moving
we met up with gm ceo mary barra at
factory zero gm's first assembly plant
for zero emissions electric vehicles
this is where they make the electric
hummer so the hummer is no longer a gas
guzzler not at all no
but a huge truck that costs more than
one hundred thousand dollars is not what
most americans want or can afford
so gm is now spending four billion
dollars to overhaul its plant in oregon
michigan to start making an electric
version of one of its most popular
models the chevy silverado pickup truck
starting price about forty thousand
dollars
you seem to be doubling down on the
pickup truck as kind of your next big
push we lead in truck share uh in this
country it is a franchise for us you
know we're going to defend our position
and we plan to grow it
the competition is fierce ford starts
delivering its electric f-150 pickup
this spring and tesla is hyping its
futuristic cyber truck
what do you think will be your true
first mass market car at a price point
most americans can afford the equinox ev
crossover is going to start at around 30
000
and we've also shared that we're working
on a vehicle that will even be more
affordable than that
barra says the transition to electric
vehicles is now inevitable it's also
seen as essential to reducing carbon
emissions from gas-powered vehicles that
are helping to rapidly warm the planet
gm believes it can drive down the cost
of evs and more quickly roll out new
models because of its customizable
battery system called ultium it's the
platform all of its future evs will run
on
gm is now building massive battery plans
in ohio and tennessee and just announced
a new 2.6 billion dollar battery
facility in lansing michigan
i think we're incredibly well positioned
and we're not going to cede our
leadership position to anyone barra is
trying to position gm as the leader in
electric vehicles promising to go all
electric by 2035
but right now tesla commands nearly 70
percent of ev sales in the u.s while gm
is only about six percent of the market
tesla ceo elon musk recently trolled gm
on twitter saying hypothetically if they
did make lots of electric cars then they
would be the leader so what do you mean
by that when you say you are the leader
when you look at how many vehicles we're
going to be able to launch across many
segments that's why by mid-decade we
think we'll be in a leadership position
so you think you can catch tesla by 2025
2026 clearly that's what we're working
from a north america perspective and
we're just going to keep going until we
have global leadership as well general
motors is issuing its second recall in
less than a year for tens of thousands
of chevy bolt electric cars there have
been setbacks last summer gm was forced
to recall all of its chevy bolt and bolt
euvs due to concerns over battery fires
the recall coupled with a shortage of
critical computer chips sent gm's ev
sales plummeting to just 26 vehicles in
the fourth quarter of last year how much
of a gut punch was that when that
happened
it's always hard but you know
one of my mantras is you have to do the
right thing even when it's hard so it
was disappointing yes but um
we just did the right thing and what do
you say to somebody now who says yeah
i'm interested in buying an ev but i'm
not sure they're safe i think people
have to look at who's got the experience
we have a lot of learnings built in to
the electric vehicles general motors is
producing
barra says guiding gm into an
all-electric future is one of the
highlights of her career
it will be a very different company and
you know i've been at general motors my
whole career and i can't i'm so excited
about where we're headed for cbs
morning's ben tracy detroit